foreign
[Music]
15 years ago
I was young red in my 20s look at me I
was so cute I was on top of the world no
I was the bottom of the world it was
terrible nobody likes me I have no
friends
recognized dogs don't like me you know
who hate me the most humans
I have one friend he was a cockroach we
got along very well his name was a
capital
and then I
ate one day
everything changed
[Music]
you was the first things I met
it didn't want to kill me or eat me
I couldn't just leave you there
was covered in these rules is someone
dumb in the source
it transformed us
because I was older I became older red
you guys with babies so you stay baby
turtle creatures if you think about that
it couldn't make more sense
it was weird but we became a family
[Music]
greetings girl and welcome
welcome
to back it's a daisy 80 about to walk
top states
[Music]
thank you
square has given us a very important
mission for tonight Target is across the
street we must use stealth and cut it to
infiltrate the human world and retrieve
Gogurt
[Music]
four quarts of
five meals yeah I like cheese this is
very specific think about the party size
he underlined it twice all right Donnie
you're on toiletries RAF you're stocking
up the pantry and Mikey you're on
junkers and remember don't let any human
see you because why you maybe are the
demon scum of the earth
and hey I know that's objectively
prejudiced but that's what Dad taught us
uh I think humans seem kind of cool to
be honest Beyonce that guy's the goat
I'd love to have a champagne brunch with
Tom Brady I fear he seems like a fun
hang and I've always wanted to go to
flavor Town look we all think humans are
cool but we got a job to do let's go
[Music]
you have bronchitis
that's a lot of guys
it looks really mean
what the heck are those things I think
it's those guys who work in Times Square
you know the mascots yeah the gecko
geckos more like little Shreks to me
this is fine
we prepared our whole lives for this
I've actually been in a fight before and
I don't know if you noticed but all I've
got is a big stick how did I end up with
a baby
you're not funny enough for that dude
about fighting every night you've got a
rage problem right that's not a problem
oh my God
[Music]
restart guys
maybe they'll see the humanity at our
tragic backstory
[Music]
I got it
come on
I'm sorry
scooter
drifting around us
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
look around
[Music]
forever
yo come on y'all let's get the goods
huh
y'all adorable man bad burning got some
turtles
we don't work for Bernie we're here to
find you I can't believe there
are wow I mean this is crazy like let me
guess 15 years ago right some sludge was
dunked in the sewer and y'all came from
that well we prefer the term ooze but
yeah it's like more like it's just nice
it's nice right ooze I like that I like
ooze so look look that same ooze made me
okay my dad Baxter Stockman he's the one
who dumped the Ooze down the drain baby
so technically we cousins
I've always wanted a cousin well look at
you now you got a bunch
boys where have you been I've been
friends
it was the cat and you know I'm scared
of cats so yeah yeah
you said you would go shopping then come
right back
where were you oh uh look we're really
sorry Splinter some of the guys want to
see a movie and I try to talk him out of
it
you watch a movie with the humans yeah
you ratted us out hey don't use that
word that way that was sorry Dad
oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my God
improv team tryouts I've gotta sign up
this is amazing Mikey what are you doing
we don't even go here yet the trash
aren't for two weeks we could be
enrolled by then they need a last name
wait what's our last name I don't I've
never thought about that actually I
don't know do we not have last names oh
who are we it's okay I'll just break it
up Michael Angelo hey I'm Michelangelo
Perfecto that makes you Leonardo
ow no
Leonardo that's a cool name Bernardo
he's sensitive
we have a very important mission for
tonight
still
and cunning to infiltrate the human
world and retrieve
Go Cards
okay Batman what I'm just trying to Hype
you guys up let's go from Seth Rogen
comes a movie that crushes for
absolutely every age
amazing insane all right tell me more
it's effortlessly cooled and Visually
stunning it's the most fun you'll have
at the movies this year
[Music]
passing very dangerous see danger for
breakfast actually I eat pizza with bits
of waffles on it
with the funniest cast ever assembled
surprise
oh man you can't stop us
we're the only ones who can do this
I'm awesome
we're brothers we fight together we're
just getting started yeah
[Music]
she sounded like a leader I do oh I do
oh I sound like such a leader and you
ruined it Ninja Turtles
remember
don't let any human see you
exclusively in movie theaters August 2nd
get your tickets now
foreign
[Music]